you
[Music]
hello there it's been a while I hope
life is treating you well fortnite
season 4 is now in week 9 and a live
event has been confirmed set for just
over two weeks away that means story
content finally returns hooray let's go
through the last few updates and take a
glimpse at the story quests that will
take us to the next chapter here's my
code if you're looking for an unreliable
content creator to support thanks very
much let's go
the lobby screen is our first peek into
the future the Chrome has now taken over
and the Paradigm puts it bluntly reality
as you know it is going to end I know
that's hurting here but there's no
changing it now reality as you know it
is going to end today on the island the
Chrome has indeed spread and has taken
the sacred Turf that is tilted Towers
which has now become tainted Towers
things aren't all bad though thanks to
the real heroes of the story no sweat
Insurance who saved themselves nine
weeks ago they've also decided to come
back and save the iconic Tower from the
Chrome lifting it moments before the
Chrome took over it but other areas have
not been so lucky no sweat have been
busy over the last Fortnight of
fortnight they can currently be found
above Chrome Jam Junction it's too late
to save anything here yet across the
pond is crack shot's cabin which now
looks like an asset from Up
[Music]
great movie this got me thinking as we
know a new chapter is imminent what if
everything that is currently being saved
been lifted off the ground by no sweat
is actually coming to the New Island
important buildings like crack shots
cabin which is needed every December for
all our free gifts this means other
much-loved pois are safe too like the
restaurants in China and the lighthouse
which is in condo for some reason
smaller pois have been given some love
too such as the cabin above the
crossroads
and this one stumped me last update the
Mansion at the very north of the island
was moved it floated over to shiny sound
complete with its fountain for some
reason it has floating platforms for
golf at the rear and I can't recall if
it had it before it moved please correct
me if I'm wrong but I think the golf
stuff is new so I'm calling it now this
means lazy links will return next season
yeah I know it's a stretch other pois
are now chromed out of existence the
Coliseum next to condo only has the
Llama statues on show everything else
including the reality tree roots are
chromified R.I.P unnamed location the
flying points of interest from the
Lagoon and the Rave cave continue to
rotate around the island and this week
they have found alongside each other by
the old rock statue in the East this
kind of feels like where we'll start the
live event Watching Over The Herald at
work you
speaking of the herald last update she
became unlockable and we were tasked
with spreading the word of her
inevitable destruction of the island to
frighten the inhabitants who did you
choose to tell I spoke to the
underwriter who took it in his stride
yeah so threats from extra dimensional
beings aren't covered by our policy this
man is our business I also delivered the
Herald's warning to Evie who says this
so this is how it happens I need to send
a transmission when Evie first arrived
on the island she proclaimed she was
part of the peace Syndicate a mysterious
group watching and waiting for something
to happen twin is another member and
this is reflected in her collection
screen a secure peace Syndicate message
was intercepted by the lupus you're
doing well Evie it's almost time to move
on to the next phase twin is on route to
assist X and when twin and Evie meet
this is said it's not time yet soon
whoever the peace Syndicate are I think
we are about to see them do something
become a bigger part of the story their
waiting is over the live event is coming
so more was added today including the
rocket League crossover many people
wanted octane is now fully in the game
and it can do some impressive stuff
flippy flippy stuff but you know me I
like weird updates and what weirder than
a chicken coop take a look see south of
the reality tree it's a recreation of
that awesome Zelda Mission you've played
I guess we gotta throw chickens in here
later this week as a quest and don't
worry there's a few of these around the
map anyone ever played Ocarina of Time
please select in the comments I'll try
and find you the aerial platforms built
for airplanes and helicopters are still
sitting dormant just waiting to be used
and we are promised and Aviation week
will arrive the first version of this
was postponed a few weeks back because
of issues but soon we shall take to the
skies again my friend the Bromance are
still on the island they don't seem to
have changed one iota this month but
this may be their last update ever so so
maybe pay them a visit one last time
after the Rock Family suddenly vanished
last season it might be these chaps next
keep your fingers crossed that they do
something in the live event
now Fort nightmares is over and Ash all
the ghouls and The Inquisitor have left
and the Star Wars random week from
nowhere has been and gone oh by the way
it was possible to destroy Vader's
Dropship using junk Rifts that's from an
unfinished myth Chaser episode I'll
probably never get around to anyway I'm
getting sidetracked after all that's
over I reckon Now's the Time to look
forward to the end of the season and a
message we'll receive from the paradigm
closed captioning not available
[Music]
the loop breaker project I think we all
know what she means by that right the
Midas live event from June 2020 man
that's really been a long time the day
we saw Midas create and build a Doomsday
Machine like no other one strong enough
to break the fabric of the loop itself
I'll link the live event if you want to
watch it again without my annoying voice
but what we did that day letters for me
a moment Escape The Loop and that was
the same day we began to unravel who the
i o were and how they control the loop
since then Midas seems to have vanished
whether he was eaten by a shark or
imprisoned in a suit of armor we don't
know we need answers and those answers
will change the future random prediction
time I can see is going back in time
maybe a chapter back on the first island
as we change the events we've lived
through just like the scientists did in
season X to change the future we have to
change the past but the Herald isn't
going down easy as if you finish the
bite quest line we know that one of our
own has been recruited against the odds
a secret agent ready to be called upon
should a war arise someone was able to
go through the nothing's daunting quests
to reach the end and receive gifts of
chrome and Gifts of unknown power
we see you're finally prepared to face
your fate But first you must prove
yourself
I'll be sure to recap that story be in
the season recap next week because it's
finally time to get hyped a new fortnite
event a new fortnite season a new
fortnite chapter I'm Adam you're awesome
here are some ligands I used my code
over the last month thank you so much
for sticking with me see ya
[Music]